[Applause]
many of you have asked us to make a
video about the Mexican elections which
are arguably the most important in the
history of Mexico but why are these
elections so important
well that's because this might be the
first time in the history of Mexico that
we say goodbye to bipartisan politics
election polls Lopez Obrador
is ten point nine points above his
biggest rival but although a minute here
because Mexico isn't even actually a
bipartisan country in fact Mexico has
had these same political party and
governments for over 70 years
yep you heard that right from 1930 until
the year 2000 every Mexican president
belongs to the Institutional
Revolutionary Party also known as PRI
from their Spanish acronym and yeah I
know we are thinking how can you be a
revolutionary and institutional at the
same time
well nobody really knows but that's the
name the party got theoretically PRI is
a center left-wing party although many
Mexicans would say they're just a
catch-all party with no clear ideology
or identity beyond simply their lust for
power still for 70 years PRI was winning
every election after the year 2000
Mexicans took a 12-year hiatus from PRI
with the conservative National Action
Party also known as PA n then in 2012
the PRI struck back and won the
presidency with Enrique Pena Nieto a guy
who now holds the title of Mexico's most
hated presidents ever and that is why
right now with Mexico about to hold
these game-changing elections on June
the first chances are that neither the
PRI nor the p-n will win office the
front-runner is this man here Andres
Manuel Lopez Obrador this has been a
worried by the Lopez open-door economic
agenda this is the third time he's run
for office and it might be the final
time Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador
as Mexicans know him am lo has policies
that put in Marley scare the SH out of
businesspeople and foreign investors
some people argue that Mexico might be
on the brink of becoming the new
Venezuela if they choose a populist
politician like him nonetheless his
worst enemy is not businessman it's
actually himself his public statements
are scaring away all the moderate voters
and that is a problem because they could
direct all of this anti AMLO sentiment
towards one of the other candidates
[Music]
that's it today's questions are why can
AMLO win this election and are there
legitimate reasons to be scared of his
presidency further we also want to look
at whether any other candidate could
really overshadow him in the election
well today good news we're gonna answer
all of those questions but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
[Music]
the big Mexican disappointment at the
beginning of the 21st century it seems
like Mexico was taking no prisoners with
plenty of natural resources like oil and
silver Mexico was one of the most
appreciated emerging economies in 2010
the country's gdp grew at a rate of 5.5%
nonetheless just like the other emerging
economies of Brazil and South Africa
Mexico went from hero to zero in 2016
Mexican GDP in u.s. dollars is at its
worst level since 2010 this is
surprising if we take into account that
Mexico has countless opportunities to
become a wealthy nation they have oil a
good climate for agriculture and all
kinds of natural resources and even more
importantly than those things they share
a border with America as you know NAFTA
is a trade agreement between Mexico the
USA and Canada and 80 percent of Mexican
exports go to Uncle Sam despite all of
this Mexico is still a mid-level income
country with low wages and a much lower
quality of life than its northern
neighbors
[Music]
so now you might be wondering well why
is this well after 70 years of a
basically one-party system with
corruption and drug trafficking going on
Mexico has almost medieval institutions
and I know you're probably thinking
right now you're thinking arse Simon's
exaggerating again well
how about you judge for yourself till
the year 2016 their judicial system had
no presumption of innocence so there
wasn't even a need for evidence in order
to convict someone in many cases a
confession obtained through torture
would be more than enough to send
someone to jail it's fitting that
academics call this the Inquisitor real
dude Ischl system add to this the drug
trafficking which has already killed
more than 200,000 people in just 11
years
[Music]
for better understanding in some areas
of Mexico narcos have more power than
the state itself and political sciences
is called a failed state situation and
this happens in many areas of Africa and
in Mexico
in other words Mexico needed more than
reforms it needed a 180 degree turn
arounds for its institutions and well it
was the man for this job well of course
that would be Enrique Pena yeah so and
his job was to do this when he got into
office in 2012 the problem is that it's
still too early for Mexicans to notice
improvements in their day to day lives
after the reforms in fact social unrest
in Mexico it actually keeps growing
[Music]
and you can add to that the fact that
Kenya Nieto's worst enemy is actually
pena nieto himself few people have
worked harder to damage their own
credibility basically yeah so has
everything one needs to become a hated
politician corruption scandals a fake
PhD title and lots of embezzlements but
this apparently wasn't enough for him do
you remember Donald Trump's election
campaign you probably do he was messing
with Mexico every other day as you can
imagine Mexicans they're not big fans of
Trump because of this well Pena Nieto's
brilliant idea was to invite Trump for
an official visit even before he became
the president and you can probably guess
what the reaction of the Mexican people
was and then we got to consider the war
on drugs first he jailed el chapo guzman
who is the Mexican version of Pablo
Escobar after that El Chapo escaped from
jail via a tunnel that was so well built
it was obvious it received help from the
police so some things up Kenya Neto is
the man people love to hate
a survey in Mexico Pena Nieto is the
Mexican president with the worst
approval rating of all time in other
words Kenyatta and his administration
epitomizes the public's ultimate
disappointments with the Mexican ruling
class so PRI is not to be trusted PA n
is not very exciting either so the
traditional candidates are not really an
option anymore so I mean what's left
well this is where AMLO comes in
his arm low there was a time when Amla
was a member of the PRI party that was
in the 1970s that this Institutional
Revolutionary Party was already more
institutional than revolutionary then
that's why an Luke left them and created
a party of his own the Democratic
Revolutionary Party the stronghold of
the true Mexican left but as you can
imagine defeating the PRI was mission
impossible until the year 2000 that year
brought the big crash of the biggest
Mexican party for one they lost the
presidency to the Conservatives and for
another they lost the mayor of the city
of Mexico to Ambler
becoming the leader of the biggest
Metropole all across Latin America is
not a small deal you get a great
showcase for your policies and this is
why six years later I'm low almost won
the presidency of the country I say what
do you do when you almost win a national
election and have become the new
left-wing rock star
well you accuse the government of
election fraud and organize lots of
demonstrations on the streets and let
your followers name you the legitimate
presidents and if family almost wins
this time around all of this could
happen again correct I said in a
democracy you can win and you can lose
but this was not a democracy
clearly the selection was unfair and
full of irregularities but now we know
his history let's have a look at his
policies basically amlo wants to undo
all of the reforms made by previous
presidents how about some examples well
here we have the energy though prior to
this law all Mexican oil was managed by
the state company Pemex this company
suffered big losses and all kinds of
corruption cases Pena Nieto and his
energy bill wanted to end this monopoly
so foreign companies could invest in the
country as a result short term wise
gasoline prices went sky-high in just a
few months
[Music]
Darla's wants to try and solve the
problem by going back to the way things
were before the same goes for the
education bill prior to the current bill
teachers unions held a lot of sway over
public education the result was lots of
protests organized by those teachers
unions and again an low wants to go
backwards and make those teachers happy
and what about drug trafficking well
Emily's plans don't stop with ending the
war on drugs which could be kind of
reasonable he wants to provide amnesty
for the big drug kingpins he's so-called
dangerous criminals and mere babies on a
peril to the corrupt politicians but the
best of his policies what we like to
call his magic tricks for example how do
we end corruption simple we write the
so-called moral Constitution and remove
the legal immunity that the members of
parliament currently enjoy this one is
especially funny because it's not
exactly the first time that a politician
has connected those two principles of
corruption and legal immunity and guess
what the least corrupt countries on the
planet Denmark and New Zealand's have
legal immunity for their members of
Parliament's then again it does seem
like a very appealing policy for
populist politicians worldwide
[Music]
anyway Adler basically seems to have
easy and quick solutions for everything
some more examples well youth
unemployment easy the government will
employ thousands of youngsters and so on
and so forth with other such examples in
other words an Lo and his brand new
political party these so-called morena
generates a lot of sympathy in half of
Mexico's society and a lot of fear in
the other half and this is a problem
because if you want to run for office
scaring your enemies might galvanize
them on Election Day so the real
question now is to what extent is AMLO
willing to moderate his agenda
popular or populist remember this name
Alfonzo Romo he's a big businessman in
Monterey and has been hired by an Lowe
to become the campaign spokesperson so
what's his mission well he's the man in
charge of moderating amla's policies and
making them more palatable for
independent voters with all the polls in
his favor
amlo needs those votes badly and Alfonso
Romo is the man for the job he comes
from the business world and supported
conservative candidates in the past in
fact many of amylose advisors come from
different backgrounds including the
conservative pan party and you can
really tell that they are softening his
rhetoric remember how I told you that
amlo wanted to revoke the energy bill
well now Afonso Romo has essentially
said look guys it wasn't that at the end
of the day we'll just renegotiate the
contracts with foreign companies that
they can stay in the country I'm low
changed his mind and now he says yes to
energy openness according to our phones
aroma but there's still a lot more last
minute moderation for example and Loeb
is from a region called Tabasco and
there there is a kind of fish called pee
that's why some people have nicknamed
him the pee so now in order to give the
impression that he will not nationalize
companies raise taxes or expropriate
properties in a Venezuelan fashion he's
launched a brand new economic agenda
called pay anomic s-- as you know money
is no big fan of risks and experiments
and with or without flashy names Mexican
businessman don't really trust down low
this is why while the elections are
getting closer and closer
this group has already found its
candidates
don't forget that Mexico unlike other
countries like France has no second
round during the presidential elections
that means that the candidate with the
biggest share of the voters on July the
1st will become the president this is
why it seems that the biggest antagonist
AMLO is going to be the Conservative
candidate Ricardo Anaya the Mexican
business elite will support Anaya in
order to stop Lopez Obrador
being 39 years old Anaya is the youngest
candidate in this election he's been
accused of money laundering that this
hasn't actually hurt him during the
campaign in fact quite the opposite is
true people believe that this was just a
dirty trick played by the PRI to
disqualify him so indeed he is gaining
momentum in the polls although he still
has a long way to go in order to surpass
and lo so now the big question is do you
believe an lo will become the next
Mexican president all that Anaya could
actually beat him is amlo a risk to
Mexico or is it hard to do worse and
previous presidents well please leave
your answer in the comments section
below and don't forget to visit our
friends from the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and don't
forget we publish brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday so don't forget to
subscribe to get those videos also hit
that thumbs up button if you enjoyed
this one and as always I'll see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]